Okay. Another protocol I'd like to talk about is SOAP. Actually,
I'm just kidding. We are not going to talk about SOAP. SOAP
is based on XML. It's another protocol for communicating between two
machines. If you ever have to deal with it, you'll know why
that I don't even want to bother teaching it. It's very,
very complicated. But what I would like to list for you are
a bunch of other common protocols and formats for communicating across
the Internet. Now SOAP is one of them. We won't be spending
any time on any of these. But lots of people use them.
For example, hip monk, a lot of our data sources communicate via
SOAP. It was invented by Microsoft to make communication online as complicated
as possible. We've got protocol buffers,
which are from Google. Similar to concept
to json, it's a way of encoding different types of data for
sending it over the wire. And there's another one called thrift. This
is by Facebook. Now you've got all sorts of like, plain text,
plus some formats. Now, these are not all. You know? SOAP kind of
defines a whole protocol. Protocol buffers are really, you know, how to encode
data. Thrift is how to encode data over the wire. These, these compare
more to JSON. Soap compares more to HTTP plus JSON. Kind of the
whole package. The protocol and the data type. Of course, you can always
just build your own plain, plain-text, you know, protocol and, and data format,
but I wouldn't recommend doing this. It's not that hard to just use
JSON instead. And then, you know, somebody else who comes along and needs
to use the service, whether it's, you know, outside of your company or
internally, they don't have to figure out, you
know, how to, you know, write all this custom
code to parse, parse your custom stuff. Because JSON
and Thrift and protocol buffers and SOAP, you can
find implementations of these in almost any language. We
mention XML and JSON. Those are also in this
list. Use something that already exists, it'll save everybody
a lot of time. I probably wouldn't use SOAP.